[Music]
what up guys this goes in here for anime
uproar and chapter 94 of attacking plane
is finally out I can't wait to talk
about it before I do obviously if you're
here and you haven't read the manga
there will be among us spoilers this is
a chapter review and if you haven't
subscribed be sure to subscribe and hit
that a notification bell because we have
a lot of attacking videos on this
channel and there are many more to come
Wow guys were crazy chapter 9 chapter 94
was I mean it was insane
we have amazing characterization some
huge secrets revealed that we've been
wondering for a while now amazing Rainer
backstory and you know well let's just
get into it
the merlion gang returns to their
hometown of libero Colts had a bit too
much to drink
again we have some characterizations on
humanization there after the failure
four years ago Rainer was about to lose
the power but he has proven himself
sense by being so loyal on the
battlefield he has shown nothing but
loyalty but then last chapter he said
save Gaby which could be dangerous to
falco because getting titan powers is
supposed to be considered an honour
right in this government so it seems
like Rainer and falco really wanted free
elion from war and not bring glory for
tomorrow laying government clearly falco
really cares for and likes Gaby even
though she might not know it but it does
make for some cute and funny scenes in
this chapter where she calls out Falco
for looking at her finally in this
chapter we get a scene of the aliens
returning back to where they come from
the Barrow
an internment zone where LD ins live and
we see the enemies of our protagonist
creating family members even Zeke
appears to be greeting his grandpa and
grandma it seems to be grisha's father
and mother this manga keeps flipping the
script on us and now we have these
characters looking so warmly at loved
ones this manga really emphasizes the
point there are no clear distinction
between good guys and bad guys one of
the saddest scenes is of Gaby who seems
to be fully brainwashed by the
government and her parents who want her
to be the greatest warrior and finally
we get to see Ryanair's family
who looks proudly and lovingly at their
son Southcoast seems to be the only one
who takes pity on an injured LDN soldier
which is interesting who clearly has
shell-shocked and is being mocked we
also find out that this soldier was in
the trenches which reminds us of world
war one and the prevalence of trench
warfare at the time although the
treatment of Aldean's in general reminds
me of Nazi Germany's treatment of Jewish
people during World War two
we then jump into a scene where Gabby
and Reiner are having dinner with their
families it is revealed that Reiner is
Gaby's cousin she refers to his mom as
aunty and it's said that they come from
the same family branch the family is
very proud of the fact that they might
have two successful warriors then Reiner
x' mother karina says if only the
devil's living on the island referring
to paradise would disappear that the LD
UNS could be happy but Reiner obviously
sees a problem with this because he has
seen that they are just as human as they
are and Gaby revealed that the merlion
people have been brainwashed to believe
that there are good LD ins who followed
the Marlay government and evil island
dwellers who are blamed for the fact
that good LD ends suffer in Marlay
people seem to have the idea that the LD
ends on parodies want to destroy the
entire world
Reiner says up to five years he spent on
the island was a living hell and that
the people there our survey corps were
Devils cruel and twisted and
unbelievably we get a rendition of the
famous and beloved potato scene told by
Reiner Reiner explains how sasha was
eating the potato with no remorse and
then when caught offered half even
though the P she offered was even close
to half because she had no intention to
share Gaby and everyone else is shocked
because sasha doesn't seem like a cruel
demon she seems normal
it's a little stupid Reiner actually
humanizes these people when the family
expects him to demonize the people of
parodies Reiner then goes on to talk
about Connie Jean Marco air and and Mika
says stating that she is willing to
follow Aaron no matter what happens oh
man you gotta love me Kazan man
Gallagher anyways he says that every day
was a nightmare but that was probably
because he saw the humanity in the
people around him and you he was
betraying them these people that trusted
him as a good friend
it was his betrayal rather than their
cruelty that made it a nightmare for him
gabby is confused and asks what he means
by a wide variety of people they're all
bad right and Ryan errs mother assures
her that they are their demons who
brought hell on earth and created
sanctuary for themselves on top of the
corpses the mainland LD ins fear when
the people of the island might come with
the colossal wall Titans to stamp out
the world which refers to the first
times warning that if attacked he would
unleash the Titans except here that
people think that the island dwellers
the people at parody's just want to
destroy the world they might do it at
any time the LD ends in Marlay are
convinced and iili believe that they
need to stop the evil LD ins on the
island and then they will be recognized
as good people by the world then we get
a flashback of Ryder's mom telling him
the same things that grisha's father was
saying she said that the LD ins were
abandoned and had demons blood flowing
through them and that they need to stay
in their cage clearly drawing a parallel
to the island of parodies where the
people are all trapped by the walls then
she reveals huge news that Ryder's dad
is a Marlin
and that is why he couldn't stay with
them Reiner as a kid decided to become a
warrior so that his mother could also
become our land or at least honorary
Marlin oh my god man this chapter is
crazy and does an amazing job of really
fleshing out writers character and
motives all of a sudden this character
seems much more complex then we get a
shot of children training in brutal
conditions in order to become our layin
warriors and of everyone getting picked
before Reiner Reiner works so hard and
eventually with a lot of work becomes a
candidate and his mother hugs him when
she hears the news and cries and it is
his mother's approval on happiness that
matters most to Reiner so he decides
that he has
become one of the nine Titans no matter
what we then see what appears to be a
younger Zeke telling the young recruits
that the attack on parodies will begin
in a few years and at only six of the
seven will inherit the powers Reiner
gets excited but another recruit tells
him that he's behind all of the rest so
he'll probably be the one left behind
the reason he even made it to this stage
is because of his loyalty and sucking up
to the Mar Lake government but then
Rainer freaks out and says he was going
to report to recruit behavior to the
government and then reveals after
getting beat up that he wants to be a
shifter so that him his mom and his dad
can finally live together as a family
oh man the fields man man it's insane
Hajime isayama can make us understand
the motives and empathize with one of
the show's greatest antagonists Berthold
believes along with the rest of the
aliens in Marlay it seems that if they
can succeed against the Devils the LD
ins and the entire world can be saved
then we say young Aaron looking at the
sky and Parman running to show him the
book of the outside that talks about the
ocean and that's the end of the chapter
you know man this chapter was insane it
did an amazing job of humanizing all
these characters and especially Reiner I
also cannot wait to see how the Aldean
restorationist may come into play later
is it possible that some of the merlion
Warriors could secretly be working for
the restorationist or change sides later
after they figure out that Marlay will
probably just kill them when they are no
longer needed to wield titan powers man
I cannot wait to see what happens next
but this next showdown is definitely
going to be a lot less black and white
than the ones in the past each LDN side
is fighting for something important to
them and almost all of their motives and
or the ones we know at least are
justifiable and reasonable from the
individual characters perspective I mean
what is going to happen Reiner is
clearly questioning Marley and ideology
at this point but will he really turn
against them especially since all his
loved ones will be disgraced or maybe
even worse if he does I can't wait to
see what happens back
let me know what you guys think about
this chapter and about what might happen
next in the comments section below
remember to smash that like button if
you enjoyed this video and subscribe for
more
attack on Titan videos until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you